I recently paid off a 100,000 bucks in
student loans during the last 3 years
I'm proud of myself for the personal
discipline and fulfillment for f for my
financial commitments towards repaying
the loans I feel a great sense of relief
but I'm afraid to tell my family my
mother feels entitled to be quote
unquote paid back for being a parent and
has actually stolen thousands of dollars
from me in the past I genuinely feel sad
that I'll never hear that she's proud of
me and Wishes the best for my future
with her without her handout expectantly
is it wrong for me to lie about my
accomplishments and pretend to be broke
in order to financially and emotionally
protect myself I don't think lying is
ever a good idea I also think there's a
middle ground between entering into
conversations parading around um I
here's the deal I don't want you to
bring down your sense of dignity and
your sense of character and your sense
of respectability by choosing to lie